the jurgen experience as are my roots
from ireland scotland germany
exactly the same yes yeah so what if
we're very sensitive we're very
i think the root of most of this is
coming from the racial issue black white
and and we need we need to define some
terms
and this i think is very helpful instead
of saying african-american
black american black negro whatever
we've had in the past
i prefer [ __ ] which is a lot of
people understand this now which is
american descendant of slavery
that that makes very clear who you're
talking about
so you can say black but kamala harris
not black
black yes black in color but not
american descendants so you would make a
clear distinction between an american
descendant of slavery and someone who
if we want to [ __ ] fix our country
yeah we got to do that if we want to fix
our country this is what we have to do
malcolm x said before he became you know
nation of islam crazy
a little off the radar for me he said
the only way to fix the racial problem
in the united states of america
is have a white man and a black man sit
down at the table and work the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out
that's what he said i've been doing that
for a year yeah i think it's a podcast
of mo facts with adam curry
but i've been talking i've been talking
to this this is exactly
he started calling me explaining to me
what [ __ ] was i was trying to figure it
out on no agenda
and we were talking for an hour once a
week i said [ __ ] it this is a podcast
and i have gotten an education in his
he's like
who's he is mo facts dot com
m-o-e-f-a-c-t-z
mo facts is that his real name his name
is mo
it's really that's short for maurice but
it's not facts is that his last name no
imagine if it was
that well he's like he was born he's
like the dalai lama well
it's like trump is 45 savage you know
you got to have your you got to have
what does that mean
45 savage 45th president 45 savage
what is 45 savage that's president trump
but what
that's his nickname a rapper called 21
savage joe
hello bro hello somehow nothing i'm
younger than you but older than you
i got lucky this time i get [ __ ]
lucky yeah anyway you're talking about
it so
listen to the country what if our
problem
okay so when when you have [ __ ]
american descendants of slavery which mo
is one right if you have [ __ ]
when politicians say the black and brown
community
they feel [ __ ] because it's not
just the very this is a group of very
special americans who deserve
to be recognized as such right this is
why they've always been led down the
path of voting democrat and now there's
all the [ __ ] is in play
so that's why black white is always
played on us because that's our weak
spot that's our achilles heel
we're embarrassed about it yeah i agree
with you [ __ ] yeah america i
love my country i love our country but
we have some [ __ ] up [ __ ] that we're
we instead of dealing with it we're
letting other people hijack us over it
that's what's going on here and and
it's not racism that we suffer from it's
nepotism
it's nepotism and i'll explain why if it
truly was
and i can tell you systemic racism
absolutely existed in america
and it went all the way up into the 70s
with no
man about the house rule when they came
up from the south and
and went into the projects created by i
guess fdr
um and you know because they they
typically ate their own food
now they're coming here to work so the
projects were created and welfare
but you could not have a man in the
house and this went into the seventies
that have patrols making sure that there
was no
family with children and a father now we
have 75 percent
of all children in america without a
father in the household
you and i we got parent privilege white
privilege parent privilege
a man my dad was you know didn't work
out that great with us
but he did put some [ __ ] into me and i
grew up and he was around and
there was some that influence was there
that's our
problem who's running black lives matter
namely one male
leader of black lives matter no it's all
women
and i have no no problem with it but i
do
question what's going on i can't argue
with you either because i i don't know
who the leaders are
oh patrice colors there's a number of
women who
um yeah and they all come from the old
radical
kind of marxist just one more thing
true communists in 1936 tried to they
wanted to come and overthrow america
this has been going on for a long time
we try to
export democracy they try to bring
socialism into us
clear we do it by blowing your country
up and rebuilding it
and they do it other ways they came in
they wanted
to propagate this message and no white
people came
but the poor black people came and so
they became
very associated with marxism and leftist
ideas
and they were basically taken through
into what is today is i guess the
democratic party
and that's not working anymore because
there's just strife and there's no real
solutions and
even the first african-american
president not
[ __ ] didn't really deliver for them
so this is this election this time right
now it's
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] with us because
of this one thing
for their own power left and right
is it oh man is it a that was an
excellent joint i smoked earlier it's
very good very good stuff
yeah congratulations thank you episodes
of the joe rogan experience are now
free on spotify that's right they're
free
from september 1st to december 1st
they're going to be available everywhere
but after december 1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love